i wanted to talk to you about the rock
and roll hall of fame you're not a guy
who votes for the rock and roll hall of
fame you're the guy who selects who's
going to be
up to vote on in the rock and roll hall
of fame you're one i'm on that committee
i'm on that committee yeah who are these
guys on the committee who do you like
where do you go i'm so fascinated by
this where do you go once a year you go
and you actually it's like it's like
choosing the po it's like choosing the
pope there's a lot of secret
the room itself is shrouded and shrouded
in secrecy but you know it's because
they're white smoke
it's there's white smoke when we've made
a decision who sits there with you dave
grohl is in that room
quest love is in that room steve van
sant is in that room there's all these
other people
really you know and we all make our case
for like who we think should be
my biggest concern is that there are
far because every year five or six
groups get in the rockville hall of fame
my biggest concern is there are far more
groups that are deserving and artists
that are deserving of getting in
then can never get in based on that
small funnel of five or
six years and tom when you say you get
up and
make a presentation you say i want rush
in the rock and roll hall of fame and
then you have to justify this do you
play
music in front of what do you do no no
no no you make it you make a you make a
pitch you make a pitch for them in my
first year it was kiss
that is the band that made me love rock
and roll let me ask you something
can you separate the artist from their
politics in other words let's say ted
nugent i'm he's the first one that comes
to mind i don't know if he's in the rock
hall of fame but ted had a pretty good
[ __ ] career he's a damn good guitar
player
yeah but we know his politics is
probably not uh similar to most of the
people at the rockwell hall
you might be surprised here that ted
news and i are good friends and and
he's someone that i would someone that i
think that you could you could make an
argument for
you can be friends with him based on
guitar and stuff like that you guys
probably don't sit around
here's how that here's how that no we no
we actually we actually like
for his 60th birthday someone reached
out to me and said we're making a video
and we're asking guitar players to you
know will you
make a video for and i you know at the
time
the the ted nugent which was sort of
known in in
in the world in general was this kind of
more you know
right-wing caricature of it was not
people were not thinking of him first
and foremost as
the guy who shredded on you know cat
scratch fever yeah exactly exactly
exactly
but then i had to think what is the
video that i'm going to make
for ryan's birthday and i thought and i
put some thought on myself it's going to
be about two things one
it's going to be things that tom morello
and ted nugent have in common
and i went down this long list of you
know like free free speech advocates
love you know our love of rock and roll
like respect for guitar this
respect for uh black artists who have
you know created rock and roll
um and then the second was things that
ted nugent taught an adolescent tom
morello about sex
and then we went through cat scratch
fever like these strange words like
the lyrics to the song cat scratch fever
the lyrics of the song
wang dang sweet poon tang which were
utterly foreign to me and you know had
to ask about on the planet
which it helped in sort of sort of an
enlightening way anyway so ted called me
up after that
yes and we you know and uh while we we
certainly have differences that he is uh
i consider him a friend no it's so great
i i would love to because i'm so
fascinated by the rock roll hall of fame
and i thought like like maybe you would
have been sort of
anti that like there shouldn't be any
competition between musicians
well i was like i just think i just
think i like the fact that it
acknowledges it acknowledges sort of
careers
and accomplishment but it needs to do so
in a way that is the
the everybody who deserves to
have that acknowledgement gets it
because people pass away you know what i
mean like
like you know and and you know like the
the new york dollars for example like
sylvain sylvain i think new york doll
should be in the rock roll hall of fame
sylvain's main just just passed away so
maybe they get in but like
it would be more meaningful if we were
able to let in you know
50 this year or something right and
really sort of
you know take care check a lot of those
boxes which remain unchecked it's like
the illuminati i got to get in that room
you